du cannabis dépénalise il usage y
compris dans des pays de l'union
européenne
ah oui des fois on croit que c'est très
lointain les pays oui donc on dépénalise
les usages on parle pas des trafiquants
mais bon maintenant il ya des pays aussi
qui vise à légaliser notamment aux états
unis
il ya actuellement huit états qui ont
légalisé c'est à dire que dans ce cas là
c'est l'état qui touche keep qui
cultivent ou qui fait cultiver et qui
touchent donc des taxes sur cette
culture et sur la vente et il paraît que
c'est assez lucratif alors juste pour
les objectifs ça rapporte
carrément c'est très lucratif l'objectif
c'est effectivement de gagner de
l'argent
là par exemple en ce qui concerne le
dernier en date c'est à dire l'état de
californie
il escompte 50 millions de dollars la
première année donc depuis le 1er
janvier donc 2018 mais pour les autres
le colorado et des autres j'ai déjà
engrangé pas mal de pas mal de taxes
dans que c'est valable pour l'état
alors alors on va y revenir parce que il
faut quand même préciser lancé oui oui
pour la martinique mais je disais bon je
parlais de pays l'union européenne et à
d'autres pays en amérique du sud et de
vous disais les états unis mais même
tout près de chez nous par exemple à la
semaine derrière la jamaïque et saint
vincent saint vincent annonce le
gouvernement 500 annonce qu'il veut
créer une industrie du cannabis médical
mais alors qu'un avis médical ça paraît
presque un paradoxe pour certains parce
qu'on vienne parler nocivité laon pour
la société c'est vrai avec les les
trafics de toutes sortes qui peut y
avoir ici ou là pour l'individu bien sûr
s'il ya effectivement un usage pas du
tout contrôlée du cannabis mais
voilà cannabis médical ça signifie quoi
exactement il ya effectivement qu'un
avis médical ah oui oui tout à fait il
est efficace dans certaines pathologies
et ça se fume pas sa semaine ans avale
un comprimé et donc si il ya un avis
médical en france
sauf que personne ne devrait publier oui
absolument ne nommer personne n'en parle
mais personne ne prescrit aucun médecin
ne prescrit enfin mais ils sont très
rares
parce qu on a du mal à imaginer en effet
que le que le cannabis est en faillite
et efficace dans certaines pathologies
c'est à certaines doses c'est oui c'est
sous certaines formes vous l'avez dit
comprimés ou des tisanes quelquefois
c'est pour traiter quoi ces peaux
traitée par exemple les contractures des
scléroses en plaques pour traiter les
nausées les vomissements de certaines
pathologies
donc c'est un médicament qui a
maintenant des indications alors mais je
vous dis que ce n est pas seulement pour
ses récents c'est valable aussi pour
jean jules et pour la france
il est également aussi pour bien
d'autres pays le cannabis médical est
entré dans les moeurs médical il est
prescrit lampard les médecins ailleurs
notamment en europe
mais il ya une réticence culturelle
française qui fait que possible et c'est
justement parce qu'on voit bien que le
débat bon il est là depuis plusieurs
années en france ait été en martinique
aussi alors il y aller les pour qu'ils
disent bon il faut arrêter là que la
répression le tout répressif concernant
cela notamment du point de vue des
considérations sanitaires et puis
d'autres qui sont très réfractaires 10
mais non c'est si on commence non pas à
légaliser mais ne serait-ce qu à
dépénaliser c'est à dire ne plus
en principe de voir infliger infliger
des peines de prison aux consommateurs
eh bien c'est la porte ouverte à toutes
sortes de dérives
concernant la consommation non seulement
le cannabis mais que cela pourrait
entraîner vers une consommation de
drogues que dangereuse plus dur
dites-moi laurence hélie son oui oui
parce qu'en effet il faut bien bien
observer que la france c'est le pays qui
a la législation la plus répressive et
c'est le pays où il y a la plus grosse
consommation de cannabis est pour cette
raison qu on est quand même très très
mal à l'aise notamment pour ce qui
concerne les services de police et de
deux et le de justice alors oui oui dans
dans ce débat et dans ce qui a amené le
gouvernement à envisager de modifier
donc la pratique en la matière est ce
que vous les autorités médicales les
autorités sanitaires ont été
suffisamment consultés impliqués dans le
processus de décision annoncée en tout
non pas du tout pas du tout donc je
pense que la wii la 1000 des cas
c'est-à-dire la mission
interministérielle a été informée
maintenant il s'agit vraiment d'une
mesure purement policière et judiciaire
maintenant pour ce qui concerne
justement la santé publique il faut
rappeler que le cannabis à des effets
nocifs notamment provoque des des
applications psychiatrique ckia tricot
pas seulement chez des personnes
dépendantes mais également dans les
premiers en quoi ce machin aussi bien je
dis je peux arriver donc notamment chez
les jeunes
donc on reste quand même avec
l'expliquent avec enfin dans l'état
d'esprit que ce n'est pas un produit
complètement anodin puisque vous disait
qu'il ya une tendance à à dépénaliser
voire même légalisé dans certains pays
c'est une les bords une égalisation très
encadrée comme vale quoi le l'uruguay ou
le paraguay yahiaoui peu pays d'amérique
du sud où s'est quasiment les regrets
mais oui donc en effet donc ses
consommations toujours encadrée alors
plus ou moins encadrées
retenez américaine et que c'est l'argent
qui compte donc si peu encadré et à
barcelone
c'est plutôt assez bien l'encadrer
laurence buisson qui est la secrétaire
général du syndicat de la magistrature
en france trouvent elles que c'est une
solution inadaptée
elle regrette que l' usage avec cette
mesure annoncée 1 alors qu'il n'est pas
encore en vigueur un faut bien rappeler
quand même que aujourd'hui à l'heure où
on parle c'est bien enfin cette mesure
n'est pas encore en vigueur et donc le
consommateur de cannabis est passible
d'une peine d'un an de prison je crois à
une amende de chez plus de plusieurs
centaines d'euros
alors elle reçut à billiers mais nous
oui plusieurs milliers d'euros donc une
solution ce serait une solution
inadaptée
cette mesure que qu'annoncé gouvernement
regrette notamment que les usages de
supplice stupéfiants soit considéré la
sous l'angle judiciaire plutôt que sous
un angle sanitaire et sociale oui c'est
ce que vous expliquer un peu oui oui oui
mais je voulais me el hadj on l'a fait
raison c'est à dire que il a fallu
répondre là ponctuellement à un problème
de surcharge des services de police mais
il ya aussi la question de la
discrimination sur les d mais qui ne
sera pas résolue parce que jusqu'ici en
effet
les chalets les jeunes gens ou les moins
jeunes des classes aisées fume
tranquillement de manière je te fais un
maniaque impunis et le évidemment celui
qui se fait prendre c'est celui des
quartiers défavorisés
ouais donc c'est elle est un peu juste
aussi sur le plan social vous même
jusqu'à ce soir c'est à dire que c'était
comme ça déjà
et ça sera ça restera comme ça parce que
ceux qui fument dans des parcs ou dans
la rue ou ailleurs comme ça d'un surtout
dans les quartiers défavorisés et bien
seront bien sûr bien sûr puni voix alors
que ceux qui sont devant les
appartements et qui fument
tranquillement mais bon voilà
discriminations persistent alors pour
pour conclure donc usage de cannabis
pour cette magistrate pourtant jeudi ne
doit plus être une infraction pénale la
seule prise en charge d'un usager doit
être sanitaire et sociale et non relever
de l'autorité judiciaire et lundi qu'il
faut aller selon elle vers une
légalisation contrôlée bon est ce que la
société française est à cela mieux
maintenant le défi quand je dis pas pour
conclure en tranchée mais aussi mais non
mais la martinique
la question c'est que l'opinion publique
martinique elle sait pas l'opinion
parisienne
oui et non qu' il ya une opinion
publique la martinique qui étaient
hostiles à cette dépénalisation et allah
et à la légalisation donc ce n'est pas
facile on n'est pas facile donc on n'est
pas encore sorti de l'auberge finalement
là et du débat concernant cette affaire
merci professeur aimé charles nicolas
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce matin
bonne journée à merci et bonne journée